parce que c'est comme ça voilà une belle
vue
voire de chabrol avec isabelle huppert
taquine ball et françois berléand nous
semble un invité ce soir voilà c'est la
première fois tous les deux vous tournez
avec chabrol écoutons ensemble ouais et
alors c'est bien à aujourd hui
malheureusement on n'a pas de scènes
ensemble
alors donc c'est françois qui vous a mis
sur le coup donc c'est un peu par hasard
c'est françois qui m'a n'a parlé de ce2
ce2 se filmer en me disant qu'il allait
tourner avec chabrol il ya moi j'adore
chabrol j'adore son travail j'ai jamais
rencontrée c'est vrai ça dit ça
gémeauxce et comme vous étiez à la baule
et il est allé déjeuner avec chabrol
voilà voilà à l'océan
un petit bar en croûte de sel voilà
d'ailleurs c'est un blanc un petit air
d'opéra et voilà 20 euros par personne
il me suis retrouvé dans dans l'
aventure dans l'aventuré un drôle
voilà une aventure qui a commencé depuis
si longtemps il ya il a une grande
fidélité que j'en ai qui travaille ça
c'est on arrive dans une petite famille
dans un sens c'est bien c'est fait je
suis très très chouette
vous avez plus de chances qu avec steven
spielberg parce qu'il part qui vous a
appelés pour munir qu il appelait votre
agent hills où paraît-il qu'on a appelé
mon parti je vais l'appeler mon agent et
que je sais pas dans la sphère est un
peu trop parce que mon agent me dis que
tu es pas libre est votre genre a dit
que vous étiez las vegas c'est vrai mais
les dégâts c'est la carte à 40 minutes
de los angeles aurait été plus facile
ouais mais j'étais pas j'étais pas grave
c'était un peu dur à vivre de se dire je
vais pas faire le casting d'un film
aussi important oui parce que ce film me
paraissait très important lors elle
s'est séparée me paraissait utile non et
puis tourner avec spielberg et puis tous
à pied puis puis la mule gym puis j'ai
vu le film je vais finalement je me pose
si grave
ils ont brigué un solide salade à ce
remarquable histoire non surtout ils ont
pris le maquis mathieu amalric
mais comme j'ai beaucoup de doutes quant
aux propos du film je suis pas mécontent
de finalement de paillettes mais comme
j'ai envie de faire un jour un film avec
spielberg veut pas dire ce que je pense
mais vous vous connaissez tous les deux
et jérôme en idole là notamment les
femmes mais bien sûr c'était bien ça un
lapin c'était magnifique
le bon vieux temps eh oui de fait bon
vieux temps a alors commencé avec bruel
c'est vraiment bien fait on va voir
cette épreuve commun avec bruel a à
priori comme ça non mais quoi que je
chante